on va ça alors parce que je suis content
de voir quelle bonne surprise quand on
me voit et mieux vous êtes du genre à
changer d'avis la dernière fois que nous
sommes vus vous n'étiez pas si
enthousiaste au frais je tiens même
plutôt souviens pas mais franchement
parler ça ne m'étonne pas chaque fois
que je rencontre des gens avec qui je me
suis disputé
j'ai toujours l'impression de retrouver
des amis ont mis très bien soudoyer aux
amis du ghana je vois que vous aviez
aussi oublier que je n'aime pas les
poignées de mains je n'oublierai plus
soyez sans crainte ça ou alors vous
n'allez pas pleurer un grand gazon comme
vous voulez vous apprendre à danser la
samba
pardon oui je suis en train de lire un
livre sur la samba brésilienne
je vous propose d'apprendre à danser la
samba je fais danser la samba équipe
type pour pratiquer ce côté de ça tout
simplement bravo mais il faut monter ça
tout de suite à casimir à caser mieux
pour toi dont vous ne savez pas que
casimir est le roi de la sambre note
certaines absolument tout le monde le
sait ici vous ne connaissez pas sa
chanson je mange du gloubiboulga et je
donne 500 morts non non non non
mademoiselle futé vous est
extraordinaire
le contrat est dans ma poche à nous de
casimir
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez vas-y casini du court le plus vite
possible
d'accord j'y vais attention mais non qui
me remet non mais il fallait pas
t'arrêter du doigt prendre ton appel
c'est à dire t'es lancé sur une seule
jambe
mon écoute c'est vraiment pas facile et
c'est encore bon allez tu vas voir cette
fois du court le plus vite possible
je vais battre mon propre corps
attention deux avocats zinnias mais mais
mais c'est nettement mieux mitigé par
françois n'ai pas peur ce monsieur l'air
assez originale dont messieurs
il est sûrement pas méchant vous aimez
ne voit quasiment on vous a dit son
plaisir de vous plaindre du monde
[Musique]
noir avec moi moi le roi du carnaval
fait c'est formidable je vais pouvoir
danser la samba vous venez danser toute
la journée tout le monde c'est une
chance unique accepte qui sera le roi du
carnaval
mais vous croyez que ceux d'en face est
bon yalouz
écoutez écoutez je vais vous faire une
démonstration 1
attendez je vais mettre mon chapeau je
verrai monsieur casimir est un danseur
exceptionnel swiss ou alors muscat à
l'ailé
[Musique]
françois est ce que tu crois que je peux
signer ce contrat
mais bien sûr que c'est dire tu sais
bien que je ne me trompe jamais monsieur
a une bonne tête du coup d'avoir
confiance en lui
le roi du carnet alors je signe à moi
mais monsieur trafic ce déguisement
odile est un vrai brésilien c'est
monsieur traoui oui c'est moi c'est bien
moi j'espérais réussir une fois de plus
ça alors françois c'est toi qui m'a
conseillé de signer ce contrat cassimir
pourtant monsieur travelling et l'air
d'un véritable danseurs oui et bien
regarde bien ce contrat l'arrière de
véritables gupta et qui va le manger et
nous donc nous recevons côté sécurité
[Rires]